تحدثت قبل قليل عن شجاعه الرئيس شيراك في
سياساته الخارجيه كما تحدث في مذكراتك
ايضا منها قرار مثلا استخدام الفيتو بوجه
الامريكيين في حربهم على العراق وغضب بوش
انذاك لو تذكرنا بهذه الحادثه لو سمحت
لقد ادركنا سريعا اي الرئيس شيراك ادرك
سريعا في عام 2002 انه كان هناك رغبه
واضحه كل الوضوح من جانب الامريكيين
لاحداث تغيير في النظام في
العراق فمحور الشر الذي
اشير اليه كان يهدف للتخلص من صدام حسين
وبالنسبه لشراك فان الدول يكون لها قاده
تختارها شعوبهم وليس دول اجنبيه فشعوب هي
التي تختار القاده ثم تحل اي مشكلات مع
هؤلاء القاده اذا الرئيس شيراك وفي حوار
في نهايه عام 2002 بمناسبه قمه لحلف
النيتو مع الرئيس بوش قال له اذا تدخلتم
في العراق
هذه العمليه ستكون اولا غير قانونيه غير
شرعيه ولن تحصل على دعم من المجتمع الدولي
والنتيجه نتيجه هذه العمليه ستكون زعزعه
استقرار المنطقه برمتها والتي هي بالاساس
هشه وكذلك توازنات الموجوده لن تكون
موجوده في المستقبل بعد العمليه وبالتالي
يبدو سيكون هناك فوضى عارمه وبتاكيد موجه
ارهاب ستكون خطيره للغايه وقد اضاف والغرب
سيفقد شرفه ولا يمكن لنا ان نؤيدكم في هذه
العمليه طبعا الرئيس بشرى انزعج كثيرا من
هذا الموقف
وكان لدينا شعور انذاك وتاكد ذلك عندما
ارسلني الرئيسي راقي واشنطن في بدايه عام
2003 قبل الحرب باسابيع ادركنا ان الهدف
كان تغيير النظام في العراق واسلحه الدمر
الشامل ذريعه فقط
لانها جاءت في نهايه اولويات الامريكيين
ببساطه لانه لم يكن هناك اسلحه دمار شامل
في العراق وبالتالي كان هذا وضع بالغ
صعوبه
وما حدث في العراق الحقيقي
وتعاته ما زال العراق يعاني منها حتى الان